[Music]
it chapter 2 is finally pranced into
theaters bringing the long bloody saga
of the losers club to a close
but we're not leaving the circus just
yet with a nearly three hour run time
and a thousand page book to reference
there were bound to be plenty of easter
eggs in it chapter 2. here are the ones
you might have missed
it chapter 2 had a lot of catching up to
do while the first film focused
exclusively on the kids
this one had the dual job of both
introducing the adult versions of the
losers
and making you believe that they really
could be those children all grown up
when we're introduced to adult ben
hanscom we see a board room with a bunch
of men arguing over the model of a
building
after the camera slides over the room it
finally focuses on one man
it's ben except it's not ben as
portrayed by jay ryan is on a skype call
with everybody in that room
but it's a double fake out because that
first guy was ben all grown up
confused see that actor was brandon
crane who played ben hanscom in the 1990
miniseries
in a story all about childhood loss of
childhood and facing the fears of your
childhood
giving an actor the chance to play both
a child and an adult in an adaptation of
it
is basically poetry speaking of cameos
there was a special one that fans of
stephen king probably
noticed but which might have flown over
the heads of casual viewers
no not the one where director andy
muschietti appeared in the background
when eddie visits the dairy pharmacy
we're talking of course about king
himself the horror auteur showed up as
the owner of secondhand rose the thrift
store where bill finds silver his
childhood bike
like king's portrayal in the film the
proprietor in the novel is kind of a
jerk
honey come on over here sugar buns
but that's not the end in the film the
shopkeeper has a copy of bill's book
attic room on his desk
after bill notices the book king repeats
what everyone else says about bill's
books
he doesn't like the ending it's a joke
that's overused in the movie but hearing
the criticism coming from king himself
is a pretty great nod to the fact that a
whole lot of readers don't like the
endings of king's books
because let's face it they're not always
great
one character the film leaves out
entirely is maturin an ancient
intergalactic turtle that sort of helps
the losers defeat it during round one of
their face-off
in the climactic scene in the kids
timeline bill performs the ritual of
chud with pennywise and ends up soaring
through a cosmic realm beyond space and
time
at which point he encounters a big old
turtle maturin comes from the same
dimension as the being known as
it and in fact created our world by
puking it out when he had indigestion
so good thing the macroverse doesn't
have pepto-bismol
while neither of the it films have dared
to quite go into that level of cosmic
craziness
they've definitely dropped a few turtle
easter eggs hit chapter 1 put a lego
turtle in georgie's room
as well as a mention of a turtle at the
quarry where the kids go swimming
in chapter 2 we see a model of a turtle
at derry elementary when ben revisits
the school to find his token
are there more scattered around the film
we wouldn't be surprised
in an effort to double down on bill's
guilt at not being able to save his
little brother
chapter 2 also brings in another kid
named dean to die right in front of bill
despite his best efforts to save him
the kid shows up three times in the film
but in the novel he only appears once
when bill is wandering around dairy and
revisits the old sewer opening where
georgia became pennywise's lunch
bill notices the kid with his skateboard
and urges him to stay away from the
sewers because there are killer clowns
afoot
if you pay close attention to the
underside of dean's skateboard you can
see that
although it's a little roughed up it
once had the same design as the overlook
hotel's carpet and stanley kubrick's
adaptation of the shiny
when the adult losers finally track
pennywise down to its underground layer
and totally flood the ritual of chud
the clown gets them all to scatter one
by one they all relive a twisted surreal
version of their childhood fears
beverly's nightmare takes on the form of
a stall in a school bathroom one that
looks a lot like the one where she got
trash dumped on her in the beginning of
the first film
to her the stall clearly symbolizes some
sort of cage
because her tormentors from over the
years begin trying to burst through the
door to taunt her
they all have something relevant to say
except crazy henry bowers who jams his
head into the gap and simply shouts the
most iconic line from the shiny
here's johnny tim curry's rendition of
pennywise in the 1990 miniseries sent
many a kid to bed with nightmares of
toothy clowns coming out of the locker
room drain
yeah it's a little goofy these days but
you can only do so much with a made for
tv special effects budget
while it's not the most fondly
remembered stephen king adaptation the
1990 version of it definitely has its
own place in history
for about 27 years tim curry was the
definitive creepy clown and no modern
adaptation worth its salted kid meat is
going to ignore it completely
in it chapter 1 we get to see a clown
with a striking resemblance to tim
curry's pennywise in the scene where
richie explores the house on nybolt
street
and in the sequel we got even more nods
to the mini series
for starters one of the most iconic
lines made a return in the 2019 film
during the flashback of young ben
hanscom hiding from it in his locker
after trying to kiss beverly
pennywise pops up with one of the most
well-known taunts from the 1990 version
you know the one kiss me fat boy
and at the canal days festival bill
chases a young boy into a clown-themed
fun house and runs into a room full of
swinging clown bags
look closely and you can see that those
clowns have the same pattern as the
outfit
from curry's pennywise right down to the
orange pom poms and curvy eyebrows
stephen king's novel spent multiple
chapters hammering home the point that
although the losers grew up physically
they each carried remnants of their
childhood into adulthood with them
in eddie's case he grew up into a man
who couldn't quite bear to leave his
mother behind
so he married her okay not literally but
eddie's wife myra
is physically and sometimes spiritually
a doppelganger of his mother
she's big needy domineering and fixated
on her husband's welfare to the point of
emotionally traumatizing him
just like mom my mom will have an
aneurysm okay if she finds out that
we're playing down here i'm serious
in it chapter 2 we only saw myra kasprak
briefly but sharp eye viewers may have
noticed a very very specific detail
namely she's portrayed by the same
actress who plays eddie's mother in both
films
molly atkinson so if you got a weird
feeling in your stomach thinking that
eddie's wife looked a little
too much like his mom you weren't wrong
if you had to name two mainstream horror
authors from the past few decades
chances are you'd be quick to come up
with two names
stephen king and dean koontz both are
prolific writers and both have been
writing published fiction for about
the same length of time obviously the
two authors have taken notice of each
other over the years
and while they probably don't have a
kind of rivalry fans think they do
they haven't been adverse to taking
shots at each other over the years
maybe that's why king wrote koontz into
it as an orderly at juniper hill asylum
who watches over and incarcerated henry
bowers
that scene where he's introduced
involves an observation from the
perspective of henry bowers that quote
koontz is the worst in it chapter 2
koontz is alive and well with an
especially fitting appearance
he's an employee at juniper hill and you
can spot him in the film as the guard
watching a dog video on his phone when
henry bowers breaks out
because of course he is dogs are magical
they're more magical than elves in the
book and to a lesser extent
it chapter 1 it often takes the shape of
movie monsters to terrify the kids
ben hanscom is scared of the mummy while
richie's fears take the form of the
hairy shapeshifter from i was a teenage
werewolf
and the oozing peeper from a 1958
creature feature called the crawling eye
because who wouldn't be scared of that
but with updated times come updated
scares and it appears that these 80s
kids found some new monster movies to be
scared of
something like john carpenter's 1982
horror masterpiece the thing
for a refresher the thing is about a
shape-shifting alien that plagues a
research team in antarctica
it can take the form of anything it
infects but it has to go through hideous
transformations to get there
in one of it chapter 2's more memorable
scenes richie bill and eddie come across
stan's decapitated head in a fridge
inside the house at 29 nybolt street
almost immediately the head grows a
bunch of freaky spider legs and richie
says
you've got to be kidding me it's a
fitting tribute to the scene in
carpenter's horror fest which sees one
of the researchers lose his head to the
tentacled monstrosity
after which palmer says you guessed it
gotta be kidding later the thing
seemingly gets referenced once again
when that adorable pomeranian behind the
not scary door shows up
and turns into a twisted dog mutant that
looks a lot like the dog that got
infected in the thing
probably the creepiest sequence in the
2017 film was when the kids go exploring
in the house on nyball street
and run into a variety of clown-flavored
horror spectacles
certainly the most memorable segment
from that sees richie and bill faced
with the scary doors
thinking on their feet they first run to
the door labeled not scary at all
and find that surprise it's pretty scary
inside they see one of the missing girls
hanging by her hands with everything
below her waist
missing well it takes
27 years but richie eventually finds
those legs
when they're back in the nighbolt house
as adults richie again comes up against
the three scary doors and the first one
he opens reveals a pair of torso-less
legs skipping towards him
guess it goes to show be careful what
you wish for
technically this easter egg breaks
through the universe of the film and
into our world which is even creepier
okay so it's not that creepy but it's
still pretty cool
most king fans know that he's big on the
number 27
and it in particular uses the number as
a main plot point
pennywise comes back every 27 years it
makes sense then that it chapter 2 saw a
release date of september 6
2019. if you break 9 6 2019 down number
by number all the digits add up to 27.
that's not a coincidence either it
chapter 1 released on september 8
2017 follows the same formula all the
digits in the date
9 8 2017 equal exactly 27 as well
add to that the fact that the first film
was released 27 years after the 1990
mini series
and well things are starting to get a
little freaky here
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you